the future of cloud is now at next but  not everyone can be there in person to  get new ideas learn from industry  experts and engage with their peers  I'm call McCandless and I am Rado Mayer  and together we'll watch every one of  over 200 sessions on Google cloud  platform 200 sessions yes over 200  sessions on Google cloud platform G  Suites Maps devices and more weight and  and more that's like that's more than  eight days of continuous sessions yes  which is why we will watch them all and  create bite-sized videos highlighting  some of the most amazing content just  for you we really thought about so join  me and me as we take you on an exclusive  tasting of Google cloud NEX distilling  200 hours of cloud content into  exquisite concentrate if you've liked  this next recap check out the other  videos in the playlist which should be  here here ok click click there